hello everyone oh thanks
my name is Lauren Lee my pronouns are
she and her thank you so much for being
here today
my talk is called why I chose to
modularize the ducks in my react at
today I'm going to walk us through a few
things we'll talk briefly about react
what problems Redux help solve will add
Redux to a react app altogether we'll
explore some of the problems within
redox and lastly I'll introduce and
propose one possible solution that
solution is contacts my journey to tech
was rather unconventional or
non-traditional if you will I didn't
study CS in college but instead was an
English teacher for seven years before
embarking on my journey of learning to
code during those years in the classroom
I spent a great deal of time lecturing
about structure and by that I mean the
five paragraph essay the art of writing
and outline rules of grammar and send
proper sentence contra construction
essentially all things structure when it
comes to a high school Lit class this
all combined with the fact that I'm a
Virgo means that I really really like
structure specifically organized
structure it ADA developers Academy a
tuition free year-long program that
trains women and gender diverse folks to
learn to code here in Seattle my peers
were constantly giving me a hard time
over my color-coded notes but in my
defense I just quit my job I had taken
this massive risk of learning to code
and this sort of stuff suits me it
brings me peace and joy and sanity while
learning to code just like my old
classroom I loved when everything had
its place I love a thoughtfully
organized codebase it genuinely makes me
smile so it should be no surprise that
later on down the road when I became a
software engineer here at Amazon
I fell really hard for react as I'm sure
a lot of us already know it has many
powerful features including the virtual
Dom native compatibility a relatively
quick learning curve helpful developer
tools and most of all the reusability of
modular eyes components ever since
learning about it I've always been drawn
to the component German architecture
that is the foundation of react I'm sure
a lot of us here are familiar with react
so I won't bore you all by explaining
the intricacies of those descriptors but
I will pause to make sure that we're on
the same page when it comes to the
modularized and reusable components when
you build with react you create a bunch
of independent isolated and reusable
components you then compose them all
together to build complex user
interfaces and the former grammar
obsessed rule-following teacher that I
am loves the encouraged organization and
division of components this implies and
finally the reusability I find that the
reusability of the components to be so
helpful for engineers plus it always
makes it so easy to find everything
within your code today I'm going to be
using a react app that aggregates
viewing data to create a most binge TV
show app this app can be divided into
components the nav the individual show
and then the ListView now the
architecture of this app is relatively
straightforward but we all know that
things can get complicated really quick
and thus developers at this point are
often forced to discover the not so
glamorous parts of react oftentimes
we'll want to pass data as props around
the app quite a bit and react advocates
for a single directional flow and things
can get messy when we want to keep our
data in sync when two or more components
share that same data ideally the source
of truth of that data is only in one
place react docs encourage us all to
live state up if you have two children
that need to access the same data this
means
the data in the nearest confessor of the
two components but if these two
components are very far apart in the
tree the nearest ancestor could be at
the top level of the component tree and
to complicate things even more the
immediate components have absolutely may
have absolutely no use for the props
that's being passed they just happen to
be stuck in the middle and have to pass
it along no thank you
my favorite analogy for this is the idea
of me wanting to tell say my cousin a
story but instead of being able to tell
her directly that story I also need to
tell my aunt now that's fine if it's you
know a little non embarrassing story but
say it's about something that I don't
necessarily want to tell my aunt about
well bummer dude I still have to pass it
through her regardless so the top
ancestor has to pass data down through
several intermediate components along
the way to get to the proper component
and just like the game telephone we
played as kids this creates a million
different opportunities for a developer
heir Oren clarity for future users the
original story can get muddled and some
can easily get confused as they tried to
trace the props as they get passed
between the many components okay
no 102 view it another way once state is
being passed back and forth and up and
down in between the component tree it's
easy to imagine how things could get
complicated and to add insult to injury
my girl sandy Metz taught me to fear
coupling and that's happening big time
between each component and its parent so
to try and move a component around what
becomes super complicated there is
coupling between the component and its
parents and between the components
children's that it's passing perhaps to
thus to no one's surprise this impacts
performance as every update made to the
data causes all of the children to
re-render which can cause massive
performance and speed issues so it's
really a balancing act there are many
great things that react brings to the
table but as you can see it's important
to find a solution from
managing an applications state if you're
hoping to ever build something more
complex than say it to do list when
we're design we're in the when we're in
the designing phase of a project we
often more often than not we we want an
abyssal two scale right we we we want to
be able to create something maintainable
for many months or years into the future
and dare I say it'd be nice to maintain
our sanity when it comes to state
management which brings me to Redux the
state container superhero that saves our
day so remember the chaos that was the
mess of passing data around our
components that is what Redux
successfully helps you make sense of
Redux is a state management tool for
JavaScript applications meaning that I
can pass data or say the embarrassing
story about my most recent Bumble
escapades to my cousin without having to
tell my aunt about it as well okay I get
to avoid the chaos of that story being
bounced between all of the components or
may many crazy uncles just to update or
change one of them and this all becomes
possible because of redox most important
principle the global store so let's talk
about that the big thing to remember is
that the entire state of application of
the application is stored in one central
location called the store meaning that
each component of your react app gets to
have direct access to the state of the
app application without having to send
props down to child components or using
callback functions to send data back up
to a parent and that's pretty dreamy
Redux provides a central store that can
hold data from anywhere in the
application to put it differently Redux
completely eliminates this messy
tunneling that can happen when you're
passing data from a parent down to many
different subcomponents and manipulating
it in all of those places now this is a
diagram of how that all happens and
today I'm going to add each piece of
Redux to my react app to show how that
all works together
so for the app I showed you earlier you
can imagine that each color here is a
different react component and currently
with just react the data in this app
flows directionally is so but I want to
add Redux so that the state of the date
and data transfer looks more like this
referring back to the redox flow diagram
the first thing we have to build is our
store it's so crucial to remember that
the store in Redux is like the human
brain it's absolutely fundamental the
state of the whole app lives inside the
store so to start playing with Redux we
should create a store for wrapping up
the state shall we all together okay to
get started we'll create a folder and
call it Redux within redox will then
create a folder for the store within the
store we'll create a file and call it
index is copy some code put it in there
and the create store function that I
have right here is the function for
creating the redux store and while you
may also pass initial state to create
store most of the time you don't have to
although passing in the initial state
can be useful for server-side rendering
traditionally the state comes from the
reducers which is what I'll do here as
it takes the reducer as the first
argument route reducer in our case but
wait I haven't actually explained what
reducers do yet I said before that state
comes from the reducer what matters now
is understanding what reducers do let's
go back to our diagram in reduce in
redux the reducers produce the state the
state is not something you can create by
hand reducers specify how the
application state changes one of the
principles of redux is that the state is
immutable and cannot change in place in
plain react the local state changes in
place with function set States but in
redox you can't do that a reducer is
just a JavaScript function
it takes two parameters the current
state and an action which is why the
reducer must be pure meaning that it
returns the exact same output for the
given input and creating a reducer is
actually pretty simple so let's do that
all together I'll pick up where I left
off and create another folder and call
it reducers within reducers a file and
XJS pop in this code
great great the reducer here is sort of
a silly one oh this this reducer here is
sort of a silly one in that it returns
the initial state without doing anything
else but definitely notice how the
initial state is passed as the default
parameter okay we've seen that good now
reducers are without a doubt the most
important concept in redox let me say it
again reducers produced the state of the
application but this should then beg the
question how does a reducer no one
should produce the next state well
that's where actions come in one of the
principles of redox is that the only way
you can change the state is by sending a
signal to the store the signal is in
action dispatching an action is the
process of sending a signal out and how
do how do you change a mutable state
well you don't the resulting state is a
copy of the current state plus the new
data and you may be thinking whoa Lauren
that's a lot of data to know but the
reassuring thing is that Redux actions
are nothing more than just JavaScript
objects this is an example of what one
might even look like okay you know the
drill
let's create a simple action all
together again we'll create a folder
actions file index jus
and plop in it ad show here today I
think it'd be fun to add the
functionality of adding a show to the
list every action requires a type
property for describing how the state
should change and it's really actually
just a strain the reducer will use that
string to determine how to calculate the
next state and you can specify a payload
just as I did if you'd like in my
example the payload is a new show ok
back to the diagram
so since types are just strings and
strings are as we know prone to typos
and duplicates it's better to have
action types declared as constants and
so it's best practice to wrap every
action within a function which
definitely helps to avoid errors so
let's also do that really quickly and
create a simple action creator
altogether again constants within
constants a file okay
and quite simple there next up I want to
open up my actions folder and I'm going
to now use what we just created I'll
remove the quotes and of course I'll
have to import it from a local store or
local directory I think I called it
constants extra types great so now we're
using that y'all still with me no okay
if not I think it'd be important to take
the time right now before we go any
further to just quickly recap the main
Redux concepts that we just implemented
so the Redux store is in charge of
orchestrating all of the moving parts
all of the state lives in a single
immutable object and as soon as the
store receives an action it triggers as
a reducer the reducer then returns the
next state the order sort of goes like
this an action first occurs within a
component say someone trying to add a
show or maybe filter the view see the
details or even delete a component then
that calls the action in action type
which then grabs the particular reducer
that will update and modify the state
and once that state has changed the view
is we rendered and tada there you have
it that is how Redux works
okay Congrats you now know everything
that there is to know about how to add
Redux to a react app and you should feel
ready to scale it to an app on your own
except you may have noticed that while
we were setting up our basic very simple
beginning of a Redux app we had to
create a bunch of folders and by oles
okay so imagine this you decide to add
all of the functionality that a
traditional app has right beyond just
adding a show maybe you want to filter
it and edit and delete whatever it is
your point if we continue down this path
it'd be easy to imagine how things could
get pretty messy or complicated
confusing really quickly because you'd
have to then edit the constants in one
file then the reducers in another and
then action creators in another and then
yet again go back and edit the actions
so you're pretty much playing tennis
emotionally physically everything right
match over here because it's just add
one single small piece of feature
functionality equates to editing and
adding several different files which
like kind of just gives me a headache
so this is a way of organizing but
you're Redux by type and that's
essentially the most common but as we
just saw you end up having to jump back
and forth between files for a single
piece of related functionality because
the constants actions action creators
are imported into the reducer file then
the action creator are also imported
into the container to be dispatched you
know all of that becomes a little
annoying wouldn't you agree but what I
found to be really wild was that there's
actually no prescribed one way of
organizing your Redux files this by type
method yes is super common and it's
taught in a ton of tutorials but
obviously it's sort of flawed my theory
is that oftentimes you when you're first
learning rate about Redux and the rules
of actions and reducers you start off
with a really simple example and most
tutorials don't take you to the next
level but if you're building something
with react or in redox that's more
complicated than a to-do list you
realize pretty quickly that you may need
a smarter way of scaling your codebase
over time these actions constants or
reduce are all related but they exist in
the fractured State and honestly
switching back and forth from file to
file yes it only takes a few seconds I
will give you that but it can make my
head a little fuzzy and slow down to
production efficiency simply put I find
it hard to maintain that's yet again all
of my English teacher organizational
habits came rushing back to me and I
knew that there
to be away to be strategic and
thoughtful with the organization of my
codebases architecture I dove into the
research and medium articles knowing
that there must be something out there
that would offer me some peace of mind
and I was right there were a lot of
ideas out there about it some people
were suggesting online that a solution
to this frustration might be to organize
your code by feature as in encapsulating
a component the container its state the
store and its behavior the actions into
a single folder all following the reacts
component concept but this means that
you'd have to tie a slice of the redux
tour to a container and that is
completely counterintuitive to the core
of what Redux promotes so I was not
about to adopt that pattern and so back
to the drawing board I went and further
research led me to ultimately
discovering the moment you've all been
waiting for based on the title of this
talk Ducks to the rescue but what are
Ducks
Eric Rasmussen who coined the term
realized that he was often creating and
editing one piece of functionality at a
time he kept needing to add action types
actions reducers tuples for each use
case just as we were he was keeping
these in separate files and separate
folders however 95% of the time it's
only one reducer an action pair that
ever needs their associated action thus
it makes more sense for the piece all
the pieces to be bundled into isolated
modules that can be self-contained and
can be packaged easily into a library
thus Ducks is essentially a proposal for
bundling reducers action types and
actions into the same file but why
specifically would this organization
structure be the solution to our problem
you might ask or rather why get excited
about dogs beyond their adorableness
factor that is well Ducks seek to solve
the issue of the toggled back-and-forth
repetitive nature of organizing by type
with ducks rather than splitting up all
the related code we can package it into
redux modules
okay that is enough talking let's
finally get to the fun part and convert
our redox to ducks
shall we great rhetorical yes I suppose
so remember our example was created the
fun of it was trying to create the
functionality of adding a show and
together right now we were going to move
the action types actions and reducers
all into just one file so we'll make a
folder call it Docs you could call it
module but for the fun of it today it'll
be ducks in a file index J is okay
let's first grab from the action types
the constant okay actually let's just
delete it and we'll pull it into our new
file and here we'll add export constable
at have to add action types here and add
show
great
oh hello okay and let the deleting begin
we get to now delete the constants
folder fantastic next up is actions we
will grab from the actions find four
right here and bring it into our new
file here we'll add actions equals okay
there we go don't forget you get two now
delete the actions holder by actions
okay and last but not least we get to
merge in and handle the reducer will
grab all of this code and bring it over
to the docs so this part of the
functionality right here is the part of
the code that loads the initial stage
that'll stay as it is and but actually I
do think I want to change this reducer
here because currently it does nothing
as I said other than returning the
initial state and we can fix that
actually pretty easily by turning it
into a switch statement which I have
right here fantastic and last but not
least let us delete the reducers folder
okay everyone right here in 21 lines of
code is officially contains all of the
functionality that we had built out
before it runs exactly the same way now
but it's modularized into a clean doc or
ducts for optimized state management
just to really bring this home remember
when we created all of those folders and
all of those files looked something like
this messy messy messy and they were
fragmented and separated from one
another well compare that mess that that
was to this new file which contains all
of the same capability in a
legible fashion I'll call that a win
okay
hopefully you do too in fact such a
little amount of code that it's it's
such a little amount of code that it's
able to fit into a single slide right
here and I have to say it was pretty
easy and/or painless to create even in
front of like a nerve wracking
environment in front of you all right so
that's the art of like duct thing if you
will is a way of structuring an app to
become more module which yes in the
world of software development and web
dev it's a sexy buzzword but like really
think about it it's a really great
things because now we it's obvious what
piece of redux is handling which
functionality and on a completely
practical level you no longer have to
scroll through masses and masses of
files before finding the one unit you're
needing to work on but this is only one
way of structuring your redox there are
plenty of other options and the simple
fact that I'm encouraging you all to
explore the ways to creatively define
what might work best for you may in fact
mean that the structure obsessed type a
person that I once was is lovely enough
to become someone who embraces ambiguity
and discovers that sometimes you can
define your own rules and doing whatever
is best for your code is ultimately the
bright choice what I love most about
Ducks is how clean and clear it is it
removes a lot of unnecessary boilerplate
and can easily add an action or a field
or an app's entire functionality to the
reducer by changing a single file I've
been on dev teams that have adopted this
structure and we were really happy with
it maybe you will be too
in conclusion I hope you're all walking
away from this talk feeling is so reacts
and redux aren't so confusing or scary
anymore
and maybe you were convinced by this
Ducks model of organization thank you so
much for listening my name is Lauren Lee
I'd love to hear about your favorite
organizational solutions or chat further
if you have any additional cracky
questions if you're interested here's
the original github repo of rasmussen
s-- proposal to learn more thank you
[Applause]